suppose we were told a fleet of
spaceships with highly intelligent
aliens has been spotted heading for
earth and they will be here in a few
years suppose we were told these aliens
might solve climate change and cure
cancer but they might also enslave or
even exterminate us how would we react
to such news Well 6 months ago some of
the world's leading AI experts warned us
that an alien intelligence is indeed
heading our way only that this alien
intelligence isn't coming from outer
space face it is coming from our own
Laboratories we must act now or within a
few years we might lose control of our
planet and our future to an alien
intelligence mark my words AI is far
more dangerous than nukes the good case
is just so unbelievably good that you
sound like a really crazy person to
start talking about it and the Bad Case
is like lights out for all of us look at
this timeline it's a ticking Time Bomb
each year shows us a different AI
experts estimate for when we'll develop
a technology that will change everything
artificial general intelligence or AGI
is an AI that is smarter than the
average human Elon Musk thinks AGI is
coming by 2026 and Dario amod the CEO of
anthropic thinks AGI is 2 to three years
away Google deepmind Chief AGI scientist
Shane leay thinks we'll have AGI by 2028
Sam mman and Jensen Hong estimate AGI by
2029 everyone has now gone from 30 to 50
years which was the estimate a decade
ago uh to 5 to 20 years the consensus is
moving towards AGI in the next 1 to 10
years just 4 years ago expert
forecasters and AI scientists predicted
that AGI was 20 years away now they
think it's just 3 years away you can see
just how surprised people were by GPD 3
and GPD 4 4 years ago experts also
predicted an AI aing genius level IQ on
the Mena test was 20 years away 3 years
ago they thought it was 10 years away 2
years ago 6 years away 1 year ago 3
years away now an AI has scored 998th
percentile on a Mena genius admission
test yes AI are literally genius level
now so what's going on why have these
timelines shrunk so dramatically it
started about 8 years ago when AI
started beating humans in specific tasks
way faster than predicted in 2016
experts predicted that AI wouldn't
Master the Japanese board game go until
20128 but that same year deep Minds
alphago beat one of the best go players
in the world Lee sidol a full 12 years
ahead of schedule seol retired in 2019
saying even if I become the number one
there is an entity that cannot be
defeated but what about the more complex
game Starcraft which has far more
variables experts predicted human level
performance by 2022 deep mindes Alpha
star achieved Grandmaster status in 2019
if anything this trend is speeding up
experts predicted that AI could write a
high school essay by 2026 gpt3 did that
in 2020 getting the equivalent to an
American High schooler's C+ grade in
2022 gbd 3.5 moved on to Legal exams and
scored 213 out of 400 on the bar exam
putting it in the bottom 10% % of human
test takers and just months later GPD 4
scored 298 putting it in the top 10% 90%
passing the bar is better than the human
rate the same technology experts thought
would struggle with writing High School
essays is now beating most American law
graduates so why are we smashing through
past predictions well that's where
things get worrying it scares the hell
out of me it's capable of vastly more
than almost anyone knows and the rate of
improvement is exponential the last big
breakthrough in AI capabilities was when
Transformer technology was introduced in
2017 which let AI models process all
parts of the input data simultaneously
rather than sequentially this is what
made chat GPT possible since then AI
progress has been exponential as
researchers figured out that the more
resources they committed to AI the more
compute and letting AI models read and
analyze more and more of the internet
the better their models got at virtually
all tasks it's reading more of the
internet and it's just throwing more
computers at the stuff that it's read on
the internet and and out pops out
suddenly it knows how to explain jokes
you're like wait where did that come
from yeah or now it knows how to play
chess for now more money and resources
directly translates to more intelligent
AIS to date Microsoft has invested 10
billion into open Ai and the CEO of
Microsoft AI Mustafa suan predicts
Humanity will be training AI models that
are a thousand times larger in the next
3 years so it looks like this huge
investment in Transformer era AI has put
us on a fast AI timeline but AI
capabilities will increase even faster
if this massive investment gives us agis
that are capable of recursive
self-improvement imagine thousands of
Highly skilled AI scientists working on
the next versions of themselves at first
the improvements might be measured in
weeks or months but once they produce
new AI models with superhuman
intelligence with the same goal of
improving AI capabilities we'll get the
same advancements in a single evening as
we got in the past few years of humans
working on the problem current AI models
already write code and AI improving
through self-learning has happened
before alphago zero beat the world's
best go player Lis AOL without using any
data from Human matches it trained by
just playing against itself running
tests over millions of simulated games
until after 48 hours it played better
than any human on earth AI is now
designing the more powerful chips it
runs on creating a recursive Loop that
is leading to exponential acceleration
the CEO of Nvidia says we're obviously
less than 5 years away from AGI because
current AI is already helping to create
the chips its future iterations will run
on in fact none of our chips are
possible today without AI literally the
h100s we're shipping today was designed
with the assistance of a whole lot of AI
Sam malman is so convinced by the
current rate of progress that he's
looking Beyond AGI at ASI in artificial
super intelligence now I no longer think
of like AGI as quite the end point that
would take us to like 2030 2031 that
will be a system that can Eclipse All
Humans combined at all cognitive tasks
just like stockfish destroys us at chess
so why aren't more people talking about
this this comes down to human psychology
it's hard for humans even experts to
build an intuition for exponential
growth take the rate of human economic
growth and Innovation for example the
world in 2024 with smartphones nuclear
power and space travel would make zero
sense to someone from 1750 it would blow
their mind because so much has changed
in those last 250 years but a person
from 1500 would be a lot less surprised
if they were transported forward in time
to 1750 people were still riding horses
fighting with swords and sailing in
boats the reason for that difference is
because the rate of growth isn't linear
it compounds over time inventions like
the microscope or computers make it
easier for new inventions to happen at
an even faster rate so it's not simply
that we're making strides it's that each
stride is longer than the last
understanding this compounding effect is
crucial for grasping how human progress
has accelerated over time but despite us
living through and benefiting from
exponential economic growth humans even
experts intuitively expect the speed of
growth in the next 30 Years to look a
lot like the last 30 years and project a
steady linear progression into the
future we draw a straight line upwards
from the past assuming that we've
already reached top speed and are going
to carry on cruising without realizing
that exponential growth actually looks
like infinitely increasing acceleration
an exponential growth happens fast let's
say you have a piece of algae in a pool
that doubles in size daily if it takes
30 days to fully cover the pool on what
day will the pool be covered not day 15
day
29 one day before you have a pool full
of algae it's only half full right now
all indications are that for future AI
progress we're at day 29 at the knee of
this graph just before things get real
crazy real fast the unintuitive nature
of exponential growth is why AI
timelines have been consistently
underestimated even by some experts who
think we're on an exponential curve
because it just feels wrong to say that
the same advancements that used to take
decades will soon take place in a few
months then every week then every day so
we're probably making two mistakes about
AI not only are we underestimating just
how soon AGI will arrive we're also
underestimating or just being unable to
imagine what exponential growth in the
intelligence of another species looks
and feels like we can't intuitively
grasp just how much more intelligent and
advanced AI will be than us once that
exponential growth takes us Beyond human
level AGI soon after 2030 I'd love to
describe in more depth what
superintelligent AI will be like when it
passes human levels of intelligence but
that's kind of the point that would be
like asking prehistoric humans to
predict modern-day space travel they're
just not going to know the closest we
can get is looking at the most advanced
chess AI model and then imagining that
it just doesn't beat us at chess but at
everything and that it's interested in
playing and winning games that we don't
even know exist okay so should we be
worried heads of Frontier AI Labs think
AI may become 1,000 times more powerful
than they are now in 3 to 7 years how do
you control an entity that's smarter
than you there are no historic examples
of a species being controlled by a less
intelligent life form we don't even know
how to control current primitive AIS
sure we can control what they say but
like any dictator will tell you
controlling what someone says is very
different to controlling what they feel
think and plan in secret even AI
researchers don't really know how their
own invention operates
it's a black box that they give inputs
to and tweak to get the right outputs
Without Really knowing what it is
they're tweaking it's better to think of
AI as a fundamentally alien intelligence
AI safety experts have warned us for
years about the danger of developing
technology we don't understand 50% of AI
researchers believe there's a 10% or
greater chance that humans go extinct
from our inability to control Ai and we
already said you would not get on that
plane if that was the chance that the
engineers who who built the plane told
you was going to happen now like I said
I don't know what it would be like to
interact with a superhuman AGI or what
that AGI would want to do to you but if
you want my best guess watch this video
next